[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING]
[CLICKING]
JASON KU: OK, welcome
back to 6.006.
We're going to have a--
at this problem session,
we're doing a quiz 2 review.
We're in a much
bigger room today.
So I have a little
bit more board space.
So I just wanted to go
through what's going
to be covered on the exam.
First off, the scope,
now, quiz 1 material
will be fair game for this quiz.
But it's not
something that's going
to be explicitly emphasized
or anything like that.
You should know that when we're
storing graph data structures
that they can achieve
certain running time
bounds and that kind of thing.
But we're really going to
be concentrating on graphs,
the six lectures that
we've had on graphs,
the two on unweighted
graph algorithms,
and the four that we had on
weighted graph algorithms that
covered the material that was
covered in the two problem
sets, problem set 5
and problem set 6.
Now, usually, this material
covers three problem sets
worth of material.
This term, it's covering two
problem sets worth of material.
So just keep that in
mind when you're studying
and you want to go look
back on previous material.
In general, there's
lots of graph problems
that we've talked
about how to solve.
There's really a small
number of graph algorithms.
But they can solve a lot
of different problems.
And so we saw two algorithms
to solve the graph reachability
problem, single source,
what is reachable from me.
And I can only search a
connected component of my graph
from me.
And the connected
component from me
is actually upper-bounded,
asymptotically
by the number of
edges in my graph.
Because a spanning tree of
my component has at least,
or has v plus 1 edges.
And so the number of
vertices I can reach
is upper bounded by the
number of edges in my graph,
asymptotically, anyway.
Then we talked about
exploring an entire graph,
even if it's disconnected,
not necessarily from a source,
just touching every
vertex in a graph.
Of course, we can just touch
every vertex in the graph.
i can look at the adjacency
representation of my graph
and just go through it.
But this is,
really, we're trying
to explore the whole graph,
maybe count how many things are
reachable from each
other in the graph.
And this is what we had--
we talked about
exploring a graph
and counting the size
of connected components
in a graph in an
unweighted graph.
And we could do this via
full BFS or full DFS.
It's basically putting a loop
around one of these graph
readability algorithms to
explore an entire graph
by exploring component
by component.
And when I'm done
with the component,
I find a vertex I haven't
reached yet before
and explore it again.
And that still gets linear
time in the graph V plus E.
Then we had special
types of graphs,
directed graphs,
directed acyclic graphs,
that we could use--
we proved this property of
if we ran DFS, full DFS,
on that graph, we could
actually get topological sort
of that graph, basically
an ordering of the vertices
in the graph, such
that all edges
go in one direction with
respect to that ordering,
all forward in that ordering.
And we could actually
use that to detect cycles
in a directed graph by just
looking at the topological sort
order and seeing if--
look at the finishing time,
the reverse finishing time
order of DFS, and just
checking to see whether it
was a topological sorter.
Because any back edge
there would correspond
to a cycle in our graph.
Because the proposition was
that if our graph was acyclic,
doing this procedure would
give us a topological order.
Then we had an
algorithm, Bellman-Ford,
that was able to detect
and find negative weight
cycles in our graph in a
way that we've presented it
in lecture.
But normally, we concentrated
on these two problems,
single source shortest
paths, and some a little bit,
all pair shortest paths, first
in the unweighted context,
and then in the weighted
context for the majority
of the lectures.
So let's move on to what those
single source shortest paths
algorithms were.
We had, kind of, to me,
increasing in generality here.
The first restriction
is DFS already
solves unweighted shortest
paths in linear time.
In the unweighted
context, that's all good.
But for weighted graphs,
regardless of the weights,
if we had this very strong
property on the graph
that the property-- that
the graph didn't have any
directed cycles,
then we could get
this in linear time
via DAG relaxation.
And then for general graphs,
we had these increasing--
or decreasing restrictions
on the weights.
First, we had the restriction
was that they were unweighted.
And that's the BFS constraint.
Or that they're non-negative,
that's the Dijkstra constraint.
And if we have no constraints,
that gives us Bellman-Ford.
And they increase in time.
In general, you want to
choose an algorithm that's
higher on this list.
But sometimes, the algorithms
higher on this list
don't apply.
If, on a quiz, you come
to a graph for which--
so it's not a DAG, but you
use DAG relaxation, that's
no longer a correct algorithm.
And so you're going
to get fewer points
than if you happen to use an
inefficient algorithm that
is correct.
So if I just-- whenever
I saw shortest paths,
I used Bellman-Ford,
it's the slowest thing.
That's probably going to
be a correct algorithm.
It's not necessarily going to
be the most efficient algorithm.
But you'll get more
points, because it
is a correct algorithm
than if you apply a faster
algorithm that doesn't
apply to your problem,
because it's not going
to solve it correctly.
Does that make sense?
So and then, in the
last lecture we had,
we talked about all
pairs shortest paths.
And really running
a single source
shortest paths from
each vertex is pretty
good in most circumstances.
We don't know how to do a lot
better for a lot of these.
And then Johnson
gives us, basically,
in this last line of
our graph restrictions
and weight restrictions, where
Bellman-Ford is right there we,
can actually get a speed up
over V times Bellman Ford
by kind of two tricks.
Reweight the-- find if the graph
has a negative weight cycles.
And if it doesn't, then
there exists a reweighting
of this graph.
So that all the weights
are non-negative.
But the shortest
paths are preserved.
And so we can use
Dijkstra V times
and get that running
time instead.
So that's an overview
of the content
that we've covered so far.
Just wanted to go--
just a brief overview of what
these algorithms actually do.
DAG relaxation finds
a topological order
of the thing using DFS
looking at the reverse order
of the finishing times.
We proved that that's a
reverse topological order.
And then we relax edges
forward in that order,
because we know that we'll have
found shortest paths distance
to everything before us before.
And we use that invariant to
prove that this constructs it
in linear time.
BFS explores things in levels.
Increasing in the number
of edges as we go out,
and I just process all of
the ones in the same level
at the same time.
And Dijkstra
generalizes this notion
by saying, well,
I don't know all
of the things that
are in the same level
per se, as I'm going.
But I can, using a clever
use of a data structure,
find the next one
I should process,
in kind of a DAG topological
relaxation order,
to find shortest paths when
the weights are non-negative.
Because in some sense, I know
that once I've reached things
from a short distance,
I will never have
to update their distance again.
That's kind of the
invariant that we're
having with Dijkstra.
And then Bellman-Ford
essentially
duplicates our graph so
that each node corresponds
to reaching a vertex
using, at most,
a certain number of edges.
And then that duplicated
graph is a DAG.
And we can run DAG relaxation.
So that's the basic idea
of all these algorithms.
When I approach
problems on a quiz,
there's a couple of
things to keep in mind.
There's kind of
two things that we
have to worry about when
you're looking at a graph
problem in this class.
The first thing is I might
not see a graph in my problem.
I mean, on quiz 2, you
know that there's going
to be a graph in your problem.
Because we covered graph
algorithms on this quiz.
But in general, some
of the word problems
you've been seeing
on your problem sets,
there's no graph
defined for you.
They give you an array of
things, or a set of things,
or some connections
between some things.
And that might be a graph
that you want to make.
But kind of defining the
graph is an important aspect
of that problem solving that
is not necessarily something
that we've covered in lecture.
We've not emphasized
that in lecture so much.
But it's something that you've
had to do on your problem sets
and something that will
appear on the quiz.
So part of this is
a modeling context.
Can you look at a real-world
situation, or maybe not
so real world, but
non-mathematical context,
and you're trying to
abstractify, put it
in the language of this class,
the mathematics of this class,
make a graph.
So that solving
one of the problems
that you know how to solve
can adequately solve the word
problem that we gave you.
This is a modeling part.
So I always suggest, when you
see a word problem on quiz 2
or on your problem
set, it's that--
see if you can state,
cleanly, an abstract problem.
Relate it that if
you knew the answer
to that abstract
problem, you could easily
solve your word problem,
can make it a little easier
to decouple the complexity
of the word problem.
Then you don't have to
think about, I don't know,
various strange
characters we come up
with in weird contexts and
their weird conditions.
If you can map that to just
a graph with a certain--
with certain properties, and
solving an abstract problem
on that graph, that
might be easier
for you to think about and apply
the material in this class.
So you don't have
to worry about,
oh, do I have to remember that
roads are connected to five
other things, or do I have to--
maybe you're given as
the input a sparse graph
or something like that.
That's a little easier
to think about when
applying this material.
And so converting your problem
into a finding a shortest path
problem, or finding
a cycle, or finding
a topological sort, or
connected components,
or a negative weight cycle, or
any of these kinds of things
can make it easier for
you to think about.
It's not fundamental material
in this class that's super--
that we need to lecture on, but
it is really important for you
when you're out
in the real world
looking at problems
to be able to make
that transformation from
a non-mathematical context
to a mathematical.
I like to think of this as a
modeling part of the problem.
But in general, once you've
got that nice abstract problem,
then in general, you
might have a graph.
But it might not be
the graph that you--
the only graph you want when
you're solving this problem.
That might be the input
graph that you have.
But in general, a lot of the
kind of tricks of this thing
is not modifying the
algorithms that we gave you.
If you find yourself trying
to modify the algorithms
we gave you, that we spent
entire lectures on proving
their correctness,
and things like that,
that's maybe not something you
want to be doing on an exam.
Because then, you're
going to be writing
pages of derivation and proof
that these algorithms work.
This unit in particular is
much more on the let's reduce
to some very powerful black
box that we showed you
how it works.
And so because that's
the framework here,
the way in which we introduce
complexity into problems
is to make the graph
non-obvious on the thing
that you're supposed to apply.
And so the graph that
we give you is the input
may be different than the
graph that you'll want
to use to solve the problem.
And here are some
strategies that you
can use to modify a graph.
If you want to store state as
you're traversing this graph,
you can expand the
number of vertices
in your graph to keep
track of what state I'm in.
I can have a different vertex
for every possible state
I could be at that vertex.
In your problem session,
you had this guy who's
drinking when he got to
bars, or every third time,
and you need to remember
how many times it's
been since I've been to a
bar, I had a drunk in a bar.
And so you can duplicate
the vertices to be
able to store that information.
Another thing, if you need to
search from multiple locations
at the same time or search
two multiple locations
at the same time,
you can simulate that
without having to run
an algorithm many times.
You can simulate that by
adding an auxiliary node,
an extra node, in your graph,
with edges to those sources
or to those things.
And run a single source
shortest path algorithm
from that super
node, sometimes we
call it, to get
better performance.
It's kind of an efficiency.
We're adding efficiency
by changing our graph
to fit the algorithms that we
know how to solve efficiently.
And then the last
thing, maybe it
helps to pre-process
the graph in some way.
Some edges in the graph that
we gave you might be forbidden
or may need to be traversed
in one direction rather
than the other, even though the
problem statement seems-- kind
of seems like they
should be traversable
in either direction.
And doing this pre-processing
of the graph could mean that you
break up your graph into--
your connected graph into a
set of disconnected components
that you need to find.
Or makes a cyclic graph acyclic.
Or it pruned part of the graph
that you don't want to explore.
I never want to
touch on my money
my way to get to a location.
So these are all really common
strategies that we have,
duplicating graph, adding
auxiliary vertices or edges
to the graph.
I don't know the context
in which we add edges.
That's an interesting question.
And then pre-processing, kind
of filtering out the graph
or transforming it in
some way to give it
properties that will allow us
to solve the problem better.
So any questions about the
problem-solving strategies that
we have or the content--
the kind of baseline
content of this class?
This is kind of an overview
of the lecture type
material, where we're
not necessarily applying
this material in lecture.
The rest of this
quiz review session
will be on applying
this material to some--
a quiz from a previous term,
some of those problems.
Yeah, question?
AUDIENCE: What are some common
ways that people lose points
when they write down--
JASON KU: What are some common
ways people lose points?
That's a great thing.
I'll add it to the
notes when we post.
So common things that
people lose points
on in this unit when
they're solving problems,
you're given a word problem,
and you don't define a graph.
It's as easy as that.
You start solving
assuming that we know what
graph you're talking about.
When the implicit graph in
the problem may or may not be
correct, but we don't--
there's no graph
defined in the problem.
So you need to define
a graph in the problem.
So that's the first thing.
The second thing
is, a lot of times,
it's really useful,
just as a strategy, when
you construct that
graph, tell us
how many vertices and edges are
in it, tell us if it's acyclic,
tell us what the weights
are on each edge.
If you don't tell us these
things, it's really hard for us
to base--
to judge your application of
algorithms based on that graph.
If there's redundancy, even if
you define, for every vertex
in my original graph I have 10
vertices, or blah, blah, blah,
and maybe you're adding a super
node, or all these things,
it can be difficult for us to
follow how many things are.
So you do that bookkeeping
for us, your graders
are going to be a lot happier.
And so common mistakes,
not defining a graph.
Not specifying your
graph completely.
And then not--
I would also suggest that
instead of just applying
an algorithm to a graph, that
you clearly state the problem
you're solving on
the graph first.
I want to solve this
problem, because we've
given you a number
of ways to solve
that problem on the graph.
And if you happen to
choose the wrong algorithm,
then maybe that's--
separating off the problem
from your implementation of how
you solve that
problem can maybe help
you get some points
for stating the problem
you're solving,
even if you choose
the wrong or an inefficient
way to solve it.
So that it can really help
decouple some of the things
that we're going to give
points on in this class.
So usually, what we're
breaking up a graph rubric
on grading in did
you describe a graph.
Did you modify it
in a way that's
going to help you
solve the problem?
Did you identify
a problem that you
need to solve on this thing?
Did you use a correct
algorithm to solve it?
Did you analyze the
runtime, usually
involves is the size of
my graph not too large,
and what is the running
time based on that graph?
And then, argument of
correctness in this unit
is basically I constructed
a graph that has properties
so that shortest paths
in this new graph
correspond to
whatever it is that I
want in the original problem.
Some statement that
links the problem
you're solving in your problem
statement to the problem
you're solving on your graph.
That's a really good
statement to have
to bring together correctness.
But aside from that
statement, you're
mostly relying on the
correctness of the algorithm.
So you don't need to do much
on the correctness side.
But forgetting to analyze
runtime is a big thing.
So those are a bunch of tips.
I'm going to add them
to the end of this slide
after the lecture.
Great question.
Any other questions?
All right, let's get
to solving problems.
All right, so these problems
that we're going to solve
are from spring '18 Quiz
2, slightly modified.
But we're just going to go
through them one at a time.
So the first problem we
have, we have an image
of black and white squares.
So it's like a pixel grid.
You think of as a
bitmap on your computer.
And what we say is each white
pixel is contained in a blob.
But what is a blob?
I don't know.
I kind of am giving you
an implicit definition
of what a blob is.
Two white pixels
are in the same blob
if they share an
edge of the grid.
So this kind of tells me
this graph has an edge.
If these pictures are
adjacent, they're both white.
That's what it means.
But an interesting part
about that definition
is that it kind
of is transitive.
If I have a white pixel
that shares an edge with--
a white pixel A that shares a--
let's start writing things
on the board, shall we?
Instead of me just
talking at you.
Right, we have kind
of a pixel grid here.
And I don't know how to
do this with a chalkboard
because it's white versus black.
I guess I have to color
in the white things.
These are all white.
All right, so these guys
are in the same blob,
because they share an edge.
These guys are in the same blob.
But because they share an
edge in the pixel grid,
these guys are also
in the same blob.
Because if these are
in the same blob,
and these are in the same blob,
there's a transitivity argument
here.
This guy needs to be in
the same blob as that guy.
And then it says that black
pixels are not in any blob.
And so I'm given
an n by m array.
I never remember
which one comes first,
but we have dimensions
of this thing is n by m.
So we have n times m pixels.
And so we're describing,
essentially, a linear time
algorithm to compute the
number of blobs in the image.
Why do I say linear time?
It's because for every
pixel in my grid,
I needed to give you a
specification of whether that
was white or black.
And so if I naively
gave you the input
of this algorithm with a
word per one of these pixels,
that would be the
input size of my--
and so even though
this looks quadratic,
the actual input size has--
is what we define as linear.
And so we're looking for
a linear time algorithm
to count the number
of blobs in the image.
OK, so what is--
this a little underspecified
as a problem, I admit.
I hate to admit
that I was involved
in this class at that time.
But the idea here
is if these are--
share an edge, then everything--
the observation here is if
I just draw this picture,
I notice that anything,
kind of, that's
reachable through
white-white connections
is going to be in the same blob.
So this is a blob, and this
is a blob, and this is a blob,
and this is a blob.
But there's no path here.
This black part is
not part of the blob.
Now, actually, there's
nothing in this specification
that doesn't say--
that says that we couldn't
have these things be
in the same blob.
So that's a little confusing,
may be a source of error.
This is a source of error that
I had when reading this problem
after a couple of years.
But when you are
looking at a problem,
if everything could just
be in the same blob,
then you just return 1, and this
problem is not so interesting.
So the right way to interpret
this problem, I mean, I
would not need n times m time.
I could just say 1.
So in some sense, I'd
like there to be something
interesting in this problem.
And having these things that are
not reachable from each other
be different blobs is kind
of the more algorithmically
interesting thing to have.
And so what is this then?
This is just a pixel grid.
There's adjacencies.
There's connections
between pixels.
But in particular,
I really only care
about the connections
between white pixels.
Hard to draw on here,
but this component
has a graph that
looks like this.
This component is
a single vertex.
This one's an edge here.
And here's a singleton there.
And if we were to
construct this graph,
we would have an
unweighted graph,
such that the number
of blobs in my image
would be the number of connected
components in this graph.
See how I'm relating
the thing that they're
asking for in the problem
to a property of a graph
that I'm constructing?
So that's really the key part
of argument of correctness
that we're looking
for is for you
to make some kind of
statement connecting the two.
Otherwise, you're just
constructing a graph.
And I have no idea what
you're doing to that graph.
You have to tell me.
It's about communication to us.
So how do I
construct this graph?
Well, I can just loop
through all of the pixels,
look at its four
neighbors, at most four,
and if those things share--
are both white,
then I add an edge.
We're going to
essentially have a graph.
construct a graph.
I told you to do this.
So what is V here?
Then V is a vertex
for each white pixel.
And I can just--
I mean, from the
beginning, I can just
walk through all the things,
find all the white vertices,
maybe I identify them
uniquely by their xy
coordinates in this grid.
That's fine.
So now I have all the vertices.
And now I want to see
what the edges are.
I can loop through the
pixels again and just
look at it for possible
adjacencies, see if any of them
are white, stick that
edge in this set.
So edge is any two white
pixels that share an edge.
So I can construct
both of these things
in order n times
m, because there's,
at most, that many vertices.
I just loop through them.
And the edges, for
each pixel, I'm
only checking a constant
number of things.
And I'm adding them to a set.
So the number of edges-- the
size of the number of vertices
in my graph is, at most, n
times m, and the number of edges
is, at most, n times m times 4.
It's upper bounded by
that, because that's
the number of adjacencies
I have in the graph.
You can probably
get a better bound
in terms of the
number of vertices.
It can be, at most, V times 4.
But that's a little stronger.
It doesn't really
matter, we're trying
to get within the order
n times m time bound.
So anything's fine here.
So that's the
graph we construct.
And then we can run
full BFS or full DFS.
We've identified a graph.
We've identified
that we want to count
the number of connected
components of my graph.
So idea, count
connected components.
And then, for example,
using full BFS or full DFS.
I wouldn't want you to write
both of these algorithms there.
But when we write
up our solutions,
we want them to cover the
space of student solutions.
And so we will
usually mention it.
You only have to
mention one of them.
And because these
run in linear time,
this also runs in n times m.
So all of these
things are n times m.
And we're gold.
Any questions on this question?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: If I were writing
down my proof of correctness
and my proof of efficiency
for this problem,
what sort of things
would you be looking for?
JASON KU: Right, so
when I'm writing down--
I've described to
you the algorithm.
And so the question is
what kinds of things
do I need to write
down when I'm proving--
when I'm arguing running time
of my algorithm and I'm arguing
correctness.
For running time,
mostly just check out
the size of your graph.
State to me what the size
of your graph is here.
In this case, it's
order n times m.
And then I state
what the running time
is of the algorithm that
I have is applied to that.
And so because full BFS
runs in O of V plus E time,
it's useful to actually
write this down.
Even though right
it's not in the terms
of our original
problem variables,
it's useful to write this down.
So that if I mess up when
plugging these variables in,
that you're showing your steps.
And so if you mess
up arithmetically,
then we can still
give you points.
But because the number
of vertices in the graph
is n times m, the number
of edges is n times m,
I add them together, it's
still order n times m,
and that would be a sufficient
for an argument of running
time.
And then as I was
saying for correctness,
most of this, the correctness
of this algorithm,
is relying on the
fact that this thing
counts connected components
correctly in my graph.
The key observation on
a word problem that I--
or even a graph
transformation problem,
is that the property
that you're wanting
of the original graph
or the original problem
corresponds to the thing
you're solving in a new graph
that you've made.
And so here, an
argument of correctness
that I would be looking for,
that we might allow some weaker
statements, is that the
number of blobs in the image
corresponds to the number
of connected components
in this graph that I made.
That's really all it needs.
But I would like a connection
between those values.
Now, why why would you be
constructing this graph
and finding connected
components if that wasn't what
your thought was?
I don't know.
But it's good, when
you're communicating,
to make sure that that's
abundantly clear that that's
why this is--
I mean, you should be able to
argue why these things are--
that is connected component.
You could say something like
because anything reachable is
in the same blob or
something like that.
So that's problem 1.
You've got these nice
mechanical boards.
So that's problem 1.
Problem 2 is a little funky.
It's been reworded a
little bit from Spring '18.
So that I could point out some
other features of this graph.
We're given a connected--
so connected is in bold, so that
might be an important property
of our graph that we're
trying to communicate
to you, a connected
undirected graph
with strictly
positive edge weights.
So they're mapping to
the positive integers
where E is the same size
as V. So the size of E
is the same as the size of V. So
I have the same number of edges
as I have vertices.
We're trying to find a order
V time algorithm to determine
a path from some vertex
s to some vertex t
with minimum weight.
So what's the first
thing I notice?
I notice that on this thing,
I've got a graph, problem 2,
we've got a graph.
It's undirected.
It's connected.
It has this weird property
that V equals E, or E equals V.
And weights are positive.
And we're asking for a
single pair shortest paths.
We want a path, the shortest
path, a shortest path
between two vertices.
Now, if we just were
given this graph
and we wanted to
solve this problem,
a very easy way to do that
would be to just say, let's
run Dijkstra on the graph.
This is a graph.
It has only positive
edge weights,
run Dijkstra on this graph.
How long does Dijkstra
take on this graph?
Idea 1, run Dijkstra.
What's the problem with this?
It applies-- we're in the
context of non-negative edge
weigths.
We can find single
source paths from s
to everything else in the graph.
And using Dijkstra, it applies,
it's a correct algorithm.
What's the difficulty
with this algorithm?
AUDIENCE: Too slow.
JASON KU: Too slow, right?
That algorithm would run in O
of V log V plus E. In this case,
these are the same.
So this is asymptotically
smaller than this one.
It runs in V log V.
So we're a little off.
We're off by a logarithmic
factor in our running time.
But this would at least
be a correct algorithm.
Whenever you approach
a problem on an exam
and you see a really stupid
polynomial algorithm that still
solves your problem
correctly, you
might as well write that
write that down in a line.
It doesn't hurt you
that much to just write
that down, because it's
possible we give you
points for that right.
But on your exam, notice
why it is not sufficient.
Notice that this,
this is V, notice
that this is not the running
time bound we're looking for.
We've got to exploit
something different.
Now, this doesn't seem--
this is a weighted context.
We have weighted paths.
It doesn't seem to be
in one of the conditions
that we can get a linear time
weighted single source shortest
path algorithm.
In particular, using BFS,
we saw a transformation
where, as long as the
sum of your weights
was linear in the combinatorial
size of your graph
we could use BFS
by making each edge
a bunch of undirected edges.
We don't have that
in this context.
And this graph is undirected.
I mean, so it definitely
contains cycles.
So we can't use
DAG shortest paths.
So how the heck can we do this?
Well, what does this
graph look like?
Here, I'm going to take a look
at this condition, V equals E.
So what does this
graph look like?
It's connected.
And it's V plus E. Well, how
many edges does a tree have?
V minus 1.
So in a sense, a tree
is the smallest number
of edges you can have
in a connected graph.
So this has one more
edge than a tree.
So really, what this looks
like, what our graph tree looks
like is some kind of tree.
And somewhere, we've got an
extra edge in this graph.
It's a tree plus an extra edge.
That's what our graph is.
So well, let's take a step back.
If I just had a tree, and I
had a weighted graph here,
undirected, and the
weights are all positive,
if any of the weights
were negative,
how could I solve this problem?
Well, every edge is
reachable from every vertex.
I can just go to that edge
and traverse a negative weight
back and forth.
And my shortest pathway would be
infinite for all our vertices.
That's not the
case we have here.
We have positive
edge weights only.
Which means shortest
paths are simple.
And actually, there's
only one simple path
between any pair of
vertices in a tree.
I basically-- there's
one thing I can do.
And in fact, if I took-- if
this was s and this was t,
that's an x.
What am I doing?
OK t, if I just ran
any unweighted short--
I mean, reachability algorithm,
I would get a tree, a BFS
tree or a DFS tree.
It would visit
vertices in some order.
Now actually, in a
tree, I have to output
a tree that connects
all the vertices.
And that would be this tree.
And so, in a sense, the paths
that I got from BFS or DFS
in this graph would be
exactly shortest paths.
I would just have to then
go and add up all the path
edge weights along the edges.
That makes sense?
OK, so BFS or DFS in
the unweighted context
can give me the shortest
path in the weighted context.
Because there's only one
simple path in this graph.
But we have a complication here.
That's not the question
that we're asking.
We have an extra edge.
And now, we have a property
where there's not just
one simple path to t.
There could be two simple paths.
I could go this way
around the cycle.
Or I could go this
way around the cycle.
So that's a complication.
But there's only one cycle.
If t is over here,
there's only one path.
So if there is only one
path, I'll be golden.
But if, basically,
the cycle can be
reached between
these two things,
I could have two simple paths.
That's the property.
We have the closest vertex on--
so this is the cycle.
There's a cycle here.
If this is the
closest vertex to s,
and this is the closest
vertex to t on the cycle,
then I could take either
path around the cycle
to get from one to the other.
And that gives me my two paths.
But this path and
this path, these
are completely edge disjoint.
In other words, any
simple path from s to t,
if I find this vertex
going through here,
it can only is one
of these edges.
Because I can't come
back to this vertex.
Once I go into it here, I
got to go out one direction,
and I can't come back.
So it's only one
of these two edges.
So the idea behind
this algorithm
is I'm going to find the cycle.
Or in particular, I'm going
to find this thing, s prime,
on the cycle, find the outgoing
two edges here, remove one,
and then do my tree search.
Basically find the shortest
path by running an undirected--
I mean, an unweighted
reachability algorithm,
which will give me a
path back to s, the only
simple path in that tree.
I get rid of this edge.
And I do that once.
And I do it again
without this edge.
So that's the idea
of my algorithm.
So how can I do--
I first have to find s prime.
How can I do that?
Well, I don't know
what this edge is.
But if I ran an unweighted
shortest path algorithm,
like BFS or DFS on here,
I would get back a tree.
Some edge of my graph
will not be in my tree.
Something like here, a
shortest path to this--
I look through, I run--
algorithm, idea 2,
first, find s prime.
OK, and I can find s prime
by run, I don't know,
a single source shortest
path unweighted--
I guess, run single
source reachability
unweighted from s using
BFS or DFS to explore
tree of my graph.
Then some edge is not in
my tree of the graph, that
will exist on the cycle,
kind of by definition.
It's connecting two
parts of my tree.
Now, I can look at those
two paths from here.
And the last one that they're
in common from s is going
to be my split point, s prime.
It's the closest one to my
source that is on the cycle.
Because I constructed
this cycle here.
So I can find edge u, v,
not in the parent tree.
So maybe this is u, v.
Not in the parent tree.
And then, find last common
vertex in paths from s to u
and s to v. That's going
to give me my s prime.
And I can do that by--
I mean, these are
each of linear size.
And I can just look
at their prefix.
I can start from s.
I can walk forward
until they diverge.
And the one before they
diverge is s prime.
That's s prime right here.
Once I have s prime,
I know what the edges
are when they diverge.
I remove one of
those from the graph.
I do the same algorithm
again to find a path to t.
And I do the same algorithm
And I see which one is shorter.
That's it.
There's only two of them.
And so I check.
Or they could be the
same path, in which case
my t is actually before
s prime on my cycle.
Does that makes sense?
So that's the idea.
The last thing is remove
an edge from s prime.
I don't even have to
be picky about this.
It has degree 3.
I can just run single source
shortest paths on all of them
and take the min.
Remove each edge from
s prime, remove--
that's rigth, for each edge from
s, remove and run SSR from s.
And one of the paths there to
t will be shortest, my shortest
path in the original graph.
Because it can't use more
than two of those edges.
That's the claim.
And this runs in linear
time, because what I'm doing
is I'm running single source
reachability once, and maybe
two more times, or
three more times,
a constant number of
times on a graph that
has size v. And this
prefix finding also only
takes order v.
And so we're done.
OK, any questions
about this problem?
No questions, all right,
we will move on to--
what's up?
AUDIENCE: There's a
hint in the title.
JASON KU: Yeah, there's
a hint in the title.
Actually, the original
version of this problem
said, instead of this E
equals V specification,
it said there's only
one cycle in the graph.
But it's in the context
of undirected cycles,
as opposed to directed
cycles, which is usually what
we talk about in this class.
We say that there's a negative
edge weight cycle in the graph
if we can--
usually, we're talking about--
we're allowing non-simple
cycles in this class.
So to remember this
property about trees
and to enforce this
property without talking
about cyclicity, I
changed the condition
for this problem
session, this review.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Could I also
just run depth-first search
on this graph?
JASON KU: Could you just
run depth-first search
on this graph to do what?
AUDIENCE: To find
the shortest path.
JASON KU: To find the
shortest path, right?
So depth-first
search on this path,
if I ran it from s,
when I got to s prime,
I would have a choice on what
the next outgoing age to do.
So if I ran depth-first search
for one of those choices,
I would find a path to t.
And then I would--
then I could run-- and that
would find a path to t.
There's only two of them,
or at most, two of them.
But then there's the possibility
I missed this other path that
could be shorter.
AUDIENCE: How would I miss it
if depth-first search has to go
through the other edge too?
JASON KU: It doesn't
go through the other.
That's the point.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
JASON KU: It won't go through.
So depth-first search will
actually go through this thing,
traverse an edge, go all
the way around this cycle,
because everything here
is reachable from here,
because it's an
undirected graph.
It will reach back to here and
then backtrack all the way.
So it will actually never
traverse this last edge
here of the cycle.
That's something you can
actually prove with DFS.
Now, you could actually,
while you're running DFS,
try every possibility.
Because MY branching factor's at
most 3 at some of these things.
So what I could do is--
or it could be at most four.
I could connect two things
with the same branching.
But in general, it's a constant.
And with every choice
DFS could make,
I could try all possibilities.
How many possibilities
would that be?
You get a blow up of the degree
of every vertex in my graph.
So the degree multiplied
by each other.
That's the number of
times I would have to run
DFS, which is exponential.
A constant degree--
so a constant
multiplied like 2 or 3,
right, multiplied the times
is 3 to the V, which is
exponential in the size
of my graph.
AUDIENCE: Can I have that if the
size of E equals the size of V?
JASON KU: Sure,
because I could still
have large branching for a
large number of vertices.
OK, great question.
All right, cool, so
that's that problem.
Problem 3, I have half an hour
for the last two problems.
I think that should be fine.
This one's-- OK, this is
Doh!-nut is the problem name.
Momer has just finished work
at the FingSprield power plant
at a particular location
p and needs to drive home
to a known location h.
But along the way, if
his driving route ever
comes within driving distance
k of a doughnut shop,
he won't be able
to resist himself
and will have to go
there and eat doughnuts.
And his wife Harge
will be angry.
OK, maybe you can get
the reference here.
Momer knows the
layout of FingSprield,
which can be modeled
as a set of n locations
with two-way roads of known
driving distance connecting
some pairs of them.
And you may assume that
no location is incident
to more than five roads.
So we've got a
degree bound here.
As well as the location-- and
he knows the locations that--
all the locations that
contain doughnut shops.
There's, at most, d of them.
Describe an n log
n time algorithm
to find the shortest driving
route from the power plant
back to home that avoids driving
within distance k of a doughnut
shop.
OK, so we got a couple
variables in here.
We've got k.
We've got d.
But a running time
bound only relies on n.
OK, I see shortest paths.
I see that--
I don't see an explicit mention
of positive distances of the--
I see lengths.
They say he knows the known
driving distance connecting
some pairs of locations.
So usually, I think if I were
writing this problem now,
I would probably be a
little bit more explicit
the distance is positive.
But that's something that you
might come into contact with.
Distances are positive.
And so we can have
negative distances here.
So I look at n log n.
I'm like, hey, what has
a log in it in this unit?
Dijkstra, maybe I
can use Dijkstra.
So let's see if we ran
Dijkstra from p to h.
So we've got-- we've
got a graph here.
We've got our graph.
So this is a word problem.
So there's no graph there.
So I have to define a graph.
So I'm going to
define a graph V, E.
And we've got V.
That's going to be
my set of locations, locations.
So this says there
are order n of them.
There's actually n of them.
And then E, what are
we going to have?
We're going to have--
it's a known pair of things,
road, roads with weight
equal to driving,
driving distance,
which, by my assumption, is
going to be greater than 0.
Now, that's not
stated explicitly.
But that would be a
reasonable assumption for you
to make on your exam.
Because distances are positive.
We would probably be more
explicit about that these days.
All right, so this is
a graph I could make.
And I have a vertex s or
a vertex p and a vertex h.
And I'm trying to find the
shortest path between them,
shortest driving
distance, driving route.
So I could run Dijkstra--
wait, so what do
I know about this?
How many edges do
I have in my graph?
I have, at most,
five per vertex.
So this is upper bounded by
5 times V, which is order V.
So I have an order
V sized graph.
That's a good thing,
order n, because n
is the number of vertices.
And so if I were to just
run Dijkstra on here
from p, doing Dijkstra on G
from any s takes order n log n.
n log n plus n, n log
n is bigger than n.
So that's a nice observation.
Maybe-- we have we
can at least afford
to use Dijkstra in this problem
to find shortest distances.
But what's the problem with
a shortest distance found
by Dijkstra in this graph.
Doughnuts, like the entire
point of the problem,
I need to avoid being too
close to doughnut shops.
So we might have a
doughnut shop here.
And we need to stay
outside of that distance k.
Or we might have another
doughnut shop here.
And so we got to find a
path that kind of goes
around these doughnut shops.
So in other words, if I
have a vertex in my graph
where I can reach a
doughnut shop within--
shop within distance k, I
can never visit that vertex.
Because then, Momer will not
be able to resist himself
and will have to
go eat a doughnut.
So that's the thing
we're trying to avoid.
So how can we do this?
Well, here's a silly thing.
I could run Dijkstra from
each of these vertices,
these doughnut shops, find
all the things reachable in k
driving distance from them.
And then remove those
vertices from the graph.
That's an idea.
But how long would that take?
That would need me to
run Dijkstra d times,
because there's
d doughnut shops.
I could run Dijkstra d times.
So that gives me a running
time bound of I run d times
to filter out the graph,
to modify this graph,
and then I do one more
to find the shortest
path if there is one.
But in general, that's going
to take d times n log n,
not n log n.
I have no bound on d,
except that it's under n.
So it could be n.
And that would give
me a bad running time.
So we're going to use
a very similar trick
here to one of your--
I think a previous
review session--
stop, there we go.
Is to, when you
want to find things,
if we want to prune a graph
from multiple locations,
one of the things we
can do is, any tricks?
Supernode, right?
I can have a vertex.
Well, maybe I don't
want to put it up yet.
OK, if I have all of these
doughnut shops, what I can do
is provide a--
I guess, I guess these are
unweighted, undirected edges.
Here, we can model all
of those directed things
by two undirected edges.
It doesn't really matter.
But here, I don't want
to be able to go back
to my supernode.
But what I'm going
to do is I'm going
to add a supernode
with edge weight, say,
0 to everything else.
And then, if I ran Dijkstra
from the supernode,
and found all vertices reachable
within distance k, well,
I didn't--
I didn't spend any of
that distance going
through this first edge.
And I didn't come back to
s, because these things
are directed into the things.
And so anything I
write as going to be
within distance k of
this doughnut shop,
but for all doughnut shops.
In some sense, I'm doing
this search in parallel.
So this is the
same trick that we
had in the you're looking
through the sewer network,
or something, and they're trying
to avoid monitors, or sensors,
or something like that.
We actually did
this transformation
and then binary
searched on a distance.
It was kind of involved.
But this is an easier example.
Now, you can actually
generalize this further.
What if each doughnut shop had
an amount that Momer liked it?
So if Momer is within a
larger distance of a doughnut
shop he really likes, he
still won't be able to resist.
But a doughnut shop that
doesn't make very good donuts,
he'll be able to resist a
shorter distance without having
to go to that doughnut shop.
So in other words, each
one of these doughnut shops
has a different k, a different
radius that Momer will allow.
Is there any way to
generalize this technique
to be able to prune all
of those vertices instead?
AUDIENCE: Put weights on it.
JASON KU: All of these
had weight 0 before,
the same weight.
I mean, the algorithm
would have worked
for any weight I put
on all these edges,
as long as I searched a
distance that weight plus k.
Here, I can just
make the distance
of this frontier for each
one of the doughnut shops
the same by modifying the
distance of the incoming edge.
So I can set the length--
the weight to the doughnut shop
with the largest radius to 0.
And then put the difference
between the largest radius
to all the other
ones, I put that is
the weight on the other edges.
And then we still have a graph
with positive edge weights.
And I can run
Dijkstra from this.
And that would generalize
this problem and something
that we've done in
some practice exams,
or in exams and problem
sets in the past.
So that's another common way.
So we filter forbidden--
there's two d's in
forbidden, or two d's.
There's a three d's,
vertices, by using supernode
plus one run of Dijkstra.
Those are the extra letters.
So on your exam,
you would probably
want to be a little
bit more explicit.
This is a summary of the things
that we just talked about.
I just talked 10 minutes
about the algorithm.
But it doesn't hurt to add
a summary at the top of what
you're going to write.
This is the approach
that we're going to have.
We're going to filter out the
vertices from G, essentially,
by running Dijkstra from
each of these doughnut shops.
But we're going to
do it in parallel
by adding this supernode.
Actually, on another
recommendation
I have for you on an exam
is that almost any problem
that we give you in this
class, can get 80% to 90%
of the points by writing
maybe three lines.
Almost, maybe not some of
the data structures problems,
but almost any
question in this class
can be solved with
not all of the points,
but most of the points, by
just writing a couple of lines.
That we know that you know
how to solve the problem.
And this would be one
of those situations.
Now, I would want, to
give you full points,
I would want all
the details here.
Did I construct a new graph?
I add this vertex here.
I have to add edges to
each of the d things.
But I've only added d more
edges and one more vertex.
So it still has this
linear size in my input.
And then I want to say that
I'm putting the weights on here
based on what the distance is.
Now, they're all
the same weight,
because I don't have
that generalization.
And then I run this thing.
And I remove all those graphs.
And I construct a new graph
from G. That's a third graph
that I'm constructing now.
But notice that the graph that
was implicit in my problem
was very different than the
graph that I'm ultimately
running a shortest
paths algorithm,
like Dijkstra, from p
to see if a path exists.
Does that make sense?
Any questions on this problem?
All right, we've got 20
minutes for my last problem.
Man, I'm not using--
I write much less than some
of your other instructors.
So I like to talk more than
I like to write, apparently.
So problem 4, let's
take a look at this.
This one is one I made up
last night, kind of fun.
Long shortest paths.
Given a directed graph having
arbitrary edge weights,
basically, these could be
positive, or negative, or 0,
and 2 vertices from the
graph, describe a V cubed time
algorithm to find the minimum
weight of any path from s to t.
OK, that sounds like
Bellman-Ford right there.
But I have this last condition.
And the last condition
is a little weird,
containing at least V edges.
So I want to short path
in terms of weight.
But I want a long
path, in some sense,
in terms of the number
of edges I traverse.
Does that make sense?
So of all paths having
at least V edges,
I want a shortest one among
them in terms of weight.
This is a weird
frickin' problem.
Usually, we're not trying to
do this max-min kind of thing.
You've got two different
quantities here
we're trying to optimize.
Anyone have any ideas on how
I could approach this problem?
What does this sound-- what does
the at least V edges sound kind
of similar to that we might
have talked about in lecture?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
JASON KU: So when we were
talking about Bellman-Ford,
we defined this thing
called a k edge weight.
It's the weight of any path
using, at most, k edges.
This kind of edge
constraint seems similar,
except it's kind of the reverse.
It's not at least, it's most--
it's not at most, it's at least.
Well, here's an
observation I have for you.
If I want a path that goes
through at least V edges,
some prefix of that path
uses exactly V edges.
That makes sense, right?
So maybe it makes
sense for me to--
maybe it might make
this problem easier
if it's not at least V edges,
but if it's exactly V edges.
Maybe I think about it that way.
That seem a reasonable other
way to think about this problem?
I knew how to do up to
a certain set of edges.
Here, we're asking for at most.
Maybe the thing in between is
a little easier to think about.
So what we're doing--
we're given a graph
G. It has any weights.
It's possible that this
graph has E lower bounded
by a quadratic in the vertices.
I have no restrictions on how
many edges this thing could be.
And so the worst thing I could
have is that this thing--
I mean, my graphs are simple.
The worst thing I
could do is have
this be quadratic in
the number of edges,
say, if it's the
complete graph, it's
the maximum number of
edges that I could have.
And I'm trying to
find, in my graph,
a path that uses a lot of
vertices, but has small weight.
Now, what's another
thing to notice here
is if I use at least V
edges, can my path be simple?
No.
Because I need to use at
least V plus 1 vertices.
And there are-- that's
more than the vertices
I have in the graph, obviously.
Now, it could go through
vertices more than once.
But it's definitely not
going to be a simple path.
So what's one thing--
what if there's a negative
weight cycle in my graph?
What's the minimum
weight of any path from s
to tee if the negative weight
cycle is reachable from s--
reachable on a path from s to t.
What is the answer
to my problem then?
Negative infinity, right?
Because certainly an
infinite length path
is going to use an
infinite number of edges.
If it's going
arbitrarily long, then I
can just run Bellman-Ford.
So that's one thing I can do.
I can just run
Bellman-Ford on this graph.
I have enough time
to do that, because E
is upper bounded by V squared.
And I V cubed time.
And if there's a negative
weight cycle on my graph,
I can know that the
minimum weight of any path
is minus infinity.
I detect that that's the
case if, basically, t
is reachable from s with
a minimum of shortest path
distance minus infinity.
That the path that
achieves that is going
to have more than V edges.
So I'm done.
And no path actually
achieves that.
But that's the infimum,
supremum, or infimum, sorry,
we're going lower bound.
I'm thinking of long paths.
So the number of edges
is approaching infinity.
But in the context where I don't
have negative weight cycles,
actually, one of
the things we showed
was that if you're reachable
not through a negative weight
cycle, or if no negative weight
cycles traversable from s to t,
then my shortest path
is going to be simple.
But that doesn't seem
to apply here either,
because we need to
have a non-simple path.
So what do we do?
So let's go back to
this idea of trying
to figure out the minimum weight
of any path using exactly V
edges.
Can we use some of the tricks
that we had in Bellman-Ford,
when we're keeping track of
the number of edges we're
going through at a given time.
That's the idea.
If we have a vertex--
if we have a new vertex for
each vertex, different versions
of it that talk about
exactly how many edges
I went through, then maybe
I can keep track of this
while I'm working on this graph.
So let's say I have multiple
layers of the graph.
This is the idea.
Maybe we start at level--
level 0, down here to level--
how many edges do I want?
I want V plus 1 vertices.
So I'm going to have V plus 1
levels, which is V. So a level
here, V, how many
levels are there?
There's V plus the 0.
And so there--
I'm going to have, for
every edge in my graph,
I'm going to take it.
So this is a directed graph.
So I direct it down
into the next level.
For each version of
this graph that I have,
I take that edge that was
originally between u and v
here in the graph.
It was originally here
in G. But here, I've
pointed all of those
edges downward.
Isn't that what we
did in Bellman-Ford?
We made one other
addition in Bellman-Ford,
to make it be the
at most property.
What was that
transformation we did?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
JASON KU: We had 0 weight
edges going from each vertex
to another.
It meant that we didn't
have to traverse an edge.
But here, if we don't
add those edges,
actually, this
transformation gives us
that any path that
goes through V edges
will be some path from
a vertex in layer 0
to a vertex in layer V. Just
because, to get down here,
I had to traverse
exactly V edges.
And they're edges of
my original graph.
Now notice this encodes
non-simple paths as well.
Because these things could go--
I could go here and back to u,
and back to v, and back to u,
if I had a cycle in my graph.
But actually, what
kind of graph is this?
This is a DAG.
So this is DAG.
Maybe, I call this G prime.
How many vertices
are in G prime?
v times v plus 1, so I'm
going to say order v squared.
And how many edges
are in my graph?
V times E, I copied every
edge, made it directed down
between each level.
There are V transitions
between levels.
And I copy each edge
for each of those.
So the number of edges is
order V times E. So this graph
is blown up.
There's a lot of
things in this graph.
But I notice that this graph
has size order V cubed is
what we're going for.
So I can afford to
construct this graph,
since V is actually
also upper bounded
by V squared by simplicity.
OK, so we have this graph.
We could find our vertex
s here, s0 up here.
And we could afford to compute
the shortest path distance
to all other vertices using
exactly V edges in my graph,
exactly.
That's what we could do.
I can find everything
reachable from s0 in this graph
and calculate the shortest
path down here at the bottom.
So I can do that
in V cubed times
because DAG relaxation is
linear in the size of the graph.
But that's not what the problem
is asking me, unfortunately.
In particular, I could
find the path to t,
to t, v. And that would give me
the shortest path using exactly
V edges.
But that's not what
I'm asking for.
I am asking for at least.
So it's possible that I get
down here to some other vortex.
And maybe there's a negative
weight path going to t.
And I want to be
able to find that.
So how can I do that?
How can I allow
paths to continue
past this an arbitrary amount?
I could have more layers.
Actually, simple
paths from any--
I mean, shortest
paths that are simple,
that use fewer
edges, here, I'm not
restricted on the
number of edges I use.
So shortest paths
in this graph are
going to be simple,
because there's no--
I can already
throw away the case
where I have negative cycles,
because I ran Bellman-Ford
at the beginning.
I can-- so I know that I'm
going to want a short--
a simple path after
I've reached V edges,
because it's never going
to be beneficial to me
to come back to a
vertex, because that will
be a path of longer weight.
This is the kind
of surgery argument
we had, both in unweighted
and weighted context.
So these are going to be simple.
So I know that I only have
to go V more layers at most.
So that's one way to look at it.
I could add more
layers of this thing,
find the shortest path distance
to all vertices using up
to 2v edges, maybe
even 2v minus 1,
but order v. And then for all
of the ones down below here,
I just look at each vertex.
And see which weight
is the minimum.
Another way-- the way
I like to look at it,
which is a little bit more fun,
I think, is once I'm down here,
I'm just trying to find simple
paths in the graph from this
vertex v--
to this vertex.
So one of the-- so
actually, have these go up.
So actually, on
this bottom layer,
I want to find short paths to
t from, actually, every vertex.
And I actually know what the
short-- just from what I did up
here, DAG relaxation
on this graph,
I knew what the shortest
path distance was from s0
to each of these vertices.
Because I did that in
V cubed time up here
with DAG relaxation.
So I could add a super node to
this thing with a directed edge
to each vertex with the
shortest-- with weighted
by the shortest path
distance I found up above.
Now, I have a graph where
any path from s0 to tv
here will be a path
that uses at least
V edges in my original graph.
because these represent
the shortest path
weights of anything
using exactly V edges.
And then the path can continue
in the original graph.
So now I have a new
graph here, such
that every path from here to
there corresponds to a path
that I'm looking for.
So I want to find a minimum
weight path in this graph.
How can I do that?
Now, this graph might
have negative weights.
AUDIENCE: Bellman-Ford.
JASON KU: I can run this with
Bellman-Ford, Bellman-Ford.
I can do that again.
Sure, why not?
Now, Jason, why couldn't we
just add a bunch of edges here?
Add our original edges here in
the bottom layer of this graph
and run b Bellman-Ford
on this entire graph?
Why couldn't I do that?
AUDIENCE: Too big.
JASON KU: It's too big, right?
The number of
vertices is v squared.
The number of edges is
potentially v cubed.
Running Bellman-Ford on
that huge, duplicated graph
would give me a v to the fifth
running time, which is awful.
In a sense, we're separating
out the complexity.
The upper part of the graph
has very nice DAG structure.
So let's do shortest paths
in that DAG structure.
And then reduce that
complexity down to just
being the thing that
has the cycles that we
are worried about.
Reduce the complexity down here.
So how big is this graph?
This graph has V
plus 1 vertices,
because I only added
one supernode here.
And it has E plus order V edges.
I want to be careful here.
But this is linear in the
size of the original graph.
So running Bellman-Ford
here only takes V times
E time, which is V cubed.
So that's two different ways
how to solve this problem.
One using a bunch
of graph duplication
and having the insights
that going, at most,
v more steps of this
graph duplication
could never get a better thing.
So I can stop.
Or recognizing
that, well, I have
this very powerful
algorithm here
that can find shortest paths,
simple paths in a graph
without negative weight cycles.
And I can use this supernode
to transfer a part of my graph
with a lot of nice structure
down to this other graph.
Any questions
about this problem?
So these are some--
we got two abstract problems for
you, two word problems for you,
with a lot of different
transformations
and a lot of different
tricks of trade.
Any of these would
be something that
has either appeared
on an exam or is
at a level of something that
could appear on your exam.
So go ahead and take a look
at the practice material
that we've posted and are
accessible from previous years'
websites.
And wish you luck in working
on graph problems on your exam.